hello everyone uh thank you for joining
us today and uh thank you to lab roots
for this opportunity to present some of
the work that we've been doing at nist
over the past few years
regarding the nist map and
biopharmaceutical reference materials
so i'm john shiel i'm the project
coordinator for the nismab reference
material
i've been with nist for about the last
10 years working on biopharmaceutical
characterization
measurements and again thank you very
much and looking forward to the
opportunity to share some of our work
so first of all we have to start out
with a nist disclaimer we will be
talking about
publicly available reference materials
today and so i will be showing some
values on the screen
but we do urge stakeholders to please
check the
most recent certificate for the
reference material if you are interested
to get any of the most up-to-date
measurements and up-to-date
values associated with the individual
reference material
so i wanted to start by giving a little
bit of a background about the national
institute of standards
and technology we are actually a
non-regulatory agency within the
department of commerce
so initially it may make you wonder why
is there a science-based organization in
the department of commerce
and the answer to that is we really are
responsible for the physical test
standards measurements and calibrations
for a whole variety of
individual measurements in individual
industries throughout the united states
so we have a very unique mission to
promote innovation industrial
competitiveness by advancing the
measurement science the standards and
the technology
with a specific focus to enhance the
economic security within our nation
so a couple of pictures of reference
materials here
the first on the bottom left here is
actually a picture of
a cholesterol in human serum so one
example of how nist actually contributes
to
various industries in this particular
case is you may go to the doctor to get
your cholesterol checked
and we have a reference material that
diagnostic companies can actually use to
calibrate their measurements calibrate
their instrumentation
and we provide a material that's
actually traceable to the actual
s-i unit of the kilogram so we know
exactly how much cholesterol is in that
bile
and everyone throughout the united
states can then calibrate their
individual measurements on this
particular vial of cholesterol so we
actually do this for a wide variety of
individual technology and measurement
types my particular expertise is in the
biological measurement space
but again nist has programs in every
type of
measurement science you can imagine this
goes from advanced mathematics and
statistics to computer science to cyber
security
and there's even a fire research program
at this so we have a very broad
range of expertise for all scientific
and engineering
backgrounds our core strength is
actually in
biological measurements and this is
primarily harnessed in two individual
divisions the biomolecular measurement
division and the biosystems and
biomaterials division
so of course a lot of the bio
measurements kind of cross paths between
both of the individual
divisions but overall we have a very
broad
range of types of analyses that we can
do so in the upper left-hand corner we
can talk about measurements for
individual biomolecules
so this can be things like dna rna
proteins and metabolites
we also can measure the analytics
associated with biomanufacturing so in
the case of biopharmaceuticals we may
use cell culture for example to produce
proteins or rna dna or portions of
protein therapeutics
viral vectors things like that that may
actually be used as a therapeutic
modality
so i also have a program in cell culture
and analysis
of the actual biomanufacturing process
on the right hand side of the circle we
have quantitative tools for cell
characterization
this could be things like cell identity
morphology viability
really looking at the individual cell
characteristics
but also in the bottom right hand corner
models and understanding cells and
population and their behavior
as well so we really do have an
infrastructure measure the entirety of
biological systems from cells to the
individual molecules
so with that measurement system we've
actually had a program specifically in
biomanufacturing so now we're kind of
getting into the protein therapeutic
space which is where we've spent
approximately the past six or seven
years
again we have a very wide program but
this is focusing mainly on the
monoclonal antibody type
characterization and analysis we've done
over the past few years
so getting a little bit deeper into the
individual types of measurements we're
able to do
on the left hand side we have protein
stability in biophysics
so i'll mention one of our reference
materials that's available that i won't
talk about too much today which is
srm1989
so this is actually a surrogate protein
particle material
it's made out of a polymer that has
refractive index characteristics very
similar to a protein particle
so you can actually see some image of
these protein particle standards in the
bottom left-hand corner
this is actually what very large
aggregated proteins look like
under a microflow imaging very similar
characteristics and this standard is
actually between a half to 25 microns in
size
and it can be used to calibrate various
types of instrumentation such as
microflow imaging
for those particulates we've also got
some very unique
capabilities within this that are rather
uncommon throughout the united states
including neutron scattering and small
angle x-ray scattering
these techniques can be very useful in
looking at the dynamics of proteins
which is sort of an emerging measurement
area in the field of biopharmaceuticals
moving down to the bottom of this triad
we have our production cell science so
obviously biopharmaceuticals like
monoclonals are prepared in various cell
systems
this can be humanized cell lines urine
cell lines etc
as we are actually developing some
reference cell lines that will express
a nist non-originator molecule that i'll
talk about a little bit
later in the presentation but we also
have proteomics based characterization
for things like the actual cho and other
cell lines that are producing those
materials
we're getting into proteomics of car t
another therapeutic area
and really looking at essentially the
production cell line characteristics
and how we can define things like
proteomics metabolism and genetic
diversity of those
production cell lines the upper right
hand corner is where my lab spends
the majority of our time my lab actually
looks at primary structure and quality
of therapeutic proteins and other
therapeutic modalities so we
predominantly use mass spectrometry
capillary electrophoresis
and hplc to characterize things such as
the primary structure
glycosylation and other protein
post-translational modifications
within this we also have a very
excellent program in higher order
structure
ranging from nuclear magnetic resonance
hdx
based mass spectrometry and recently
we've had electron
microscopy capabilities so we really do
have an emerging infrastructure for
higher order structure
and of course looking at things like
biological activity through
surface plasmon resonance secondary and
tertiary structure measurements as well
so as you can see nist really does have
a very broad range of measurement
capabilities
this is absolutely not an exhaustive
list but
certainly we are able to measure the
protein characteristics of relevance to
the quality
and manufacturing of these products so
they talk about measurements
on biopharmaceuticals obviously there's
a wide variety of analytical
measurements
when we start thinking about our monocle
antibody we start thinking about what
attributes about this protein we
actually want to measure
and if you look at a monoclonal antibody
initially you start thinking a reference
material that's
a common material that can be shared
among people
to do things like harmonize analytical
methods it's hard to choose
which which analytical or excuse me
which monoclonal antibody is it that
you'd actually like to use
for that analysis when we start to look
at the molecule
every monoclonal antibody has two light
chains it has two heavy chains
you can see the individual cis markings
on this particular structure those are
disulfide bonds
every monoclonal antibody also has these
disulfide bonds
either within the same chain such as the
cysteine 22 in the upper left hand
corner
or between these two chains as you can
see in the cis 222
229 in the middle of this
figure so in addition to that you can
see we have these sort of
different shapes there's the triangles
and the circles and the squares that are
sort of
peppered throughout this individual
molecule in both the heavy and the light
chain
so these are meant to represent various
low abundance post-translational
modifications
so on the right-hand side i have a
couple of different post-translational
modifications
for example methionine oxidation where
the sulfur residue of this
individual amino acid can get oxidized
we have asparagine deamidation
where the nh2 group can actually be
changed to an oh group
so we're going from an asparagine to an
aspartic acid and then very importantly
we have glycosylation
so in the bottom right hand corner you
can see this polypeptide chain with the
asparagine highlighted
and i have three different glycans
highlighted here
now i can say that this individual
glycosylation site which there are two
of on the
nisbab material one in each heavy chain
there's actually been 40 different
glycans that we've identified
on this material and any individual
asparagine
at this particular location on any
individual molecule the nist map
can have any one of these 40 glycans
attached
so you can imagine that there's
significant heterogeneity added to the
structure or the population of these
monoclonal antibody materials simply by
this one post-translational modification
so going back to the structure on the
left hand side thinking about the
monoclonal antibody as a platform
it's true that each individual type of
monoclonal antibody
is going to have different levels of
methionine oxidation
they'll have slightly different
post-translational modifications
they'll even have slightly different
sequences at the top of the structure
in the fab region but when we start
thinking about these attributes and how
we're going to measure them
every monoclonal antibody we're going to
approach in the same way
we're going to use the same measurement
techniques to look at these attributes
whether it be the primary sequence
the post-translational modification
aggregation size variance et cetera
we're going to approach that measurement
challenge in the same way so when you
start thinking about in that direction
it really is possible to have a common
material
that can be utilized to do some
harmonization throughout the industry
so in this case we started to talk to
our small biotech our large biotech and
our
federal collaborators and we did
actually get that message
that everyone should be using a common
standard it would be great to have
something that was shared that we could
have joint system suitability criteria
and in the bottom here with live large
biopharma the more robust these
standards
are the better off we'll be when we
start to develop attribute specific
monitoring assays which i'll talk about
a little bit later today they can really
look at each of these individual
decorations
on the monoclonal antibody material
in very high specificity
so in comes the nist map reference
material 8671
so the nist map is a publicly available
and biopharmaceutical
grade monoclonal antibody so this is
publicly available from nist
we actually sell our materials on a cost
recovery basis so this is
uh not for profit so we try to make
these as
uh as low price as possible to try to
get the
greatest impact and the most
distribution and availability of these
materials
they're also available for certain
collaborations within nist and i'll talk
about some of the differentiation
with the lifecycle plan but essentially
this material is publicly available
it's intended to be voluntary meaning
that manufacturers of biopharmaceutical
products are not required to use this
material
but we hope that they use it as sort of
a product neutral standard
that they can use for the internal and
external collaborations
making any data that's generated about
this molecule pre-competitive
that the entire community can utilize to
advance the field further
the material has been very exhaustively
characterized in fact we started this
project
in 2014 and 2015.
in the upper right hand corner you can
see this acs symposium series
this is actually a book that we had
recruited about 100 individuals
throughout industry and academia
to apply each of the analytical methods
on the bottom right hand corner
each of the individual chapters talks
about a certain characterization
analytical technique so it actually has
sort of a background and a how-to manual
is the introduction
and then it has real data discussion
materials and methods
on characterization of the nist map so
this is sort of a documentary
historical standard as well as
best practices for each of the
individual analytical methods
we then moved forward from that
exhaustive characterization
and we did a series of but
analytical qualifications so essentially
evaluating the precision
robustness and quality of each of those
analytical assays
that could inform on the stability or
purity of the molecule
this is highlighted in the analytical
and bioanalytical chemistry cover on the
right hand side
i'll talk a little bit more about these
articles
but herein we describe the reference
values the stability and the homogeneity
of this material that we've assigned at
nist
to assure the long-term availability of
this material
to our stakeholders so in the end the
mismat material really does provide
an industry-wide shared resource can be
utilized for novel technology
development
for de-risking new analytical approaches
before they're applied
in a regulatory filing and we think that
this can be used really for a variety of
collaborative studies to sort of address
child shared challenges within the
community
to really assess current analytical
capabilities in state of the art
and again evaluate the sort of
regulatory readily readiness of new and
emerging analytical techniques
so we've been focused uh since release
of this material in 2016
over the past few years then uh ramping
up our analytical efforts to develop
innovative technology
and also again perform interlaboratory
studies to evaluate the current state
of characterization of some of these new
techniques
so before i get into talking about the
qualification
uh analytical methods and sort of you
know interlaboratory studies
i wanted to mention something about the
life cycle management of this product
because
it really is unique for a nist reference
material and although it's modeled after
a biopharmaceutical
development program it really is unique
in the fact that we need to make sure
that this material
is available with the same attributes
for the long term
so in the upper left hand corner you can
see the bulk material that we received
this is the bulk misband material 100
mix per ml
we actually diluted one lot of this
material to make
it as our primary sample so this is our
in-house
primary standard material and also our
collaboration material
we use this for the acs books that i
mentioned before as well as our early
method qualification
we then took the remainder of this bulk
material
and as you'll see in the top side here
we've actually homogenized multiple lots
of the bulk
into what we're calling the homogenized
bulk so this is to ensure that we don't
have a lot to lock
reproducibility issues down the road so
we actually homogenized a large quantity
right up front
froze it at negative 80 degrees celsius
and we have multiple one liter aliquots
of this material as our homogenized bolt
now each container of homogenized bolt
can be diluted ten fold
and we can make ten thousand units for
each individual dilution lot
where we've initially prepared three of
these dilution lots
14 hb-d-001 for example
each lot again 10 makes for rail 800
microliters per vial
that are now available to the
stakeholder community
so the bottom right hand corner this is
sort of also our measurement hierarchy
so you can of course see the working
reference
homogenizing these bulk materials in the
middle
into the 14 hb at 14 hb
goes into the top near the
commercialization letter
and here's where we have our individual
dilution lots that are available to the
public
in the middle then below that you'll see
the nist working reference slot
this is actually the same material
that's our first commercial lot but we
use this
internally for all of our analytical
development our routine
research etc so we're sort of doing a
continuous monitoring of this sample
as time goes on and then you'll see that
primary
nist primary reference lot in the bottom
this is our sample that on an annual
basis we do a
direct comparison between anything
that's our internal
primary standard as well as whichever
lot is currently available to the public
and we do this correct direct evaluation
to ensure quality
and consistency of this material as it
goes to the public
so i mentioned quality and consistency
this is a highlight of those
analytical and bioanalytical chemistry
papers these are actually all published
online
and they are the analytical methods
we're using to monitor the quality of
the nismat material
so in the upper quadrant we see this
first people really discusses the life
cycle and the quality plan in more
detail if you're interested in that
we follow this by three individual
papers one on
size ciaf and cze excuse me charge
cief and cze the middle we have
a qualification of methods based on size
so this is capillary electrophoresis
again
uh using sodium pentacle sulfate size
exclusion chromatography
dynamic light scattering and microflow
imaging
and then we have a paper on the identity
using peptide map
to confirm the identity of the nist map
and finally we have the paper on value
assignment
stability and homogeneity where we've
actually assigned values to the lots
available to the public
all of this final paper the value of
assignment stability and homogeneity is
summarized very succinctly
in the report of investigation that
actually comes to the individual user
and this is where you can find those
values associated with the material
to know what our measurements actually
revealed for the individual attributes
of
charge heterogeneity size heterogeneity
and identity
of this individual material
so once we've had this material now
publicly available
we now have initiated interlaboratory
measurement comparisons
so this is actually an extension also on
the acs books where we've
selected a number of emerging analytical
techniques
and those that could sort of use an
interlaboratory assessment of
things like the potential sources of
variability and precision amongst these
individual assays
how these assays are actually being
performed in the biopharmaceutical
industry
so it could potentially identify places
where additional development may be
needed
it also informs nist on potential
reference materials
and i think most importantly it fosters
collaboration amongst the global
biopharmaceutical community
to really advance these analytical
technologies to the next stage
so most of these have been published the
two-dimensional nmr glycoanalysis
and hdx round robin have been published
and i'll share just a little bit of
information about the multi-attribute
method in that interlaboratory study
which we've recently submitted to mabs
and should be available in the next
couple months
so first and foremost what is the
multi-attribute method this is something
you may have heard about
in the literature at various conferences
and it really is an extension of what we
think about is peptide mapping
so in the upper left-hand corner we have
our monoclonal antibody this can be
digested using an enzyme such as trypsin
and you can see then these gray bars
indicating the peptides and the black
bars indicating the glycopeptides that
may be
making up that individual monoclonal
antibody we'll then analyze these
peptides and
glycopeptides with liquid chromatography
hyphenated to
mass spectrometry and we can use then
the mass spectrometry to again confirm
that primary sequence
identify and qualify quantify
post-translational modifications
and perform site-specific glycan
identification and quantification as
well
so the multi-authoring method actually
starts during the development phase much
as a mass spectrometry based
peptide mapping would whereas each
individual peptide or group of peptides
coming out of the chromatogram
chromatograph in this case in the ms-1
box we're actually showing
a fictional example where we have three
peptides coming out at the same time
the mass spectrometer will select each
of those individual peptides
moving from left to right across the
collision cell will actually collide
each peptide with a collision gas the
peptide will fall apart
into its constituent components and we
can essentially then piece back together
this puzzle from the ms2 fragmented
spectra
back to tell us the identity of the
individual peptide that was measured in
the ms-1
and then we can combine all of that
information to essentially confirm the
primary structure post-translational
modifications
and glycosylation sites of the
monoclonal antibody
so during this mam development phase
we've eventually identified and archived
the master charges or the signals that
we'll see
for each of the individual peptides that
are generated from our digest
we can now move into the implementation
phase which is unique to multi-attribute
method
where we're actually monitoring just the
mass to charge or the first signals of
those peptides
so we're no longer doing collision this
allows for a more
robust and accurate quantification of
the individual peptides
and you can see then the reference
sample versus a test sample
which in multi-attribute method we run
back to back
and what this allows us to do is both
check the reference sample to say
yes indeed i am getting the relative
abundance of each of those individual
peptides that i expect
telling me that my system is working
appropriately or my system suitability
sample
and then i run my unknown test sample so
i can look at this test sample to do a
couple things
so one i can definitely look at each of
those individual signals ensure that
on a mass to charge basis we're getting
the same relative abundance
of certain attributes that i want to mop
to monitor
but also i can do new and change peak
detection to directly compare the test
sample to the reference sample
without any preconceived notion of what
the identities of those peaks are
so i'll talk about that in a little bit
more detail in the next couple slides
so this is a little bit of a different
representation of mass spectrometry
this is using some software that we've
been
utilizing the past couple of years to
look at
analysis of these peptides so on the
right hand side you can actually see
that we've
sort of moved this chromatogram we
showed in the previous slide
to be the y-axis and now on the x-axis
we're showing the mass to charge of the
individual peptide ions
so what you can imagine is each of these
individual signals on the right hand
side
let's look at the tallest peak for
example i'm on the right hand side and
then as you move from right to left
you'll see sort of these clusters of
individual peaks right that are these
different colors
so each of those clusters is actually an
individual peptide
of a different charge state potentially
or different isotopes of that same
peptide
so if we actually circle around one of
these groups of ions and we were to
fragment that group of ions
you would now see this new box pop-up
pop-up that is actually the
fragmentation spectrum of that peptide
so you can see labeled peptide this is
actually that parent ion
and then you see these little labels
that say y and b
these are actually fragment ions where
individual amino acids
are essentially falling apart from that
peptide and again this is sort of like a
puzzle that we can piece back together
to actually get the identity of this
peptide in this case we have the gps vf
plav ssk peptide which is again a short
peptide
from the nisba material it's safe to say
that each of these individual spots is
representative of a signal
in the mass spectrum that we can then
identify and associate with a given
peptide
and once we've essentially identified
these peptides we can put bounding boxes
from where that signal will appear
and we can continuously quantify that
peptide based on its mass to charge
instead of a uv signal which is far less
selective
than all of this mass information that
we're able to glean by using a mass
spectrometer
so zooming a little bit closer in on one
of those individual peaks
this is actually a peptide that we call
the penny peptide
as you can see in the upper right hand
corner of the spread
of the spectrum the end residue spelled
penny k
hence the name but this is an important
peptide because you'll see the ends here
are the asparagine residues and each of
these asparagine residues can deamidate
so this is that post-translational
modification that i mentioned earlier
that has the nh2 group going to an oh
group
so we see moving into this figure the
unmodified
arrow points to the parent peptide but
when you have that nh2 to oh you
actually gain one dalton
mass so now if you look at the d329 for
example
you can actually see that that signal
has shifted a half of a dalton forward
this is because we're looking at a
doubly charged peptide in this
particular case
what we can actually do is do an
extracted ion chromatogram
of that section and you can actually see
the relative abundance of the various
peaks so these are
the iso d or the isospartic acid
diluting before the unmodified peak
the unmodified and then various
combinations of deamidation
of individual residues combined residues
in the double demitation for example
so we can now associate these relative
abundances on a very
mass specific level you can actually
quantify the iso-aspartic acid the
unmodified in each of the individual
deamidation events
and we can do that based on mass as
opposed to just a
signal signal associated with the uv so
we can actually get much higher
selectivity for our quantification
to again monitor individual attributes
of this peptide
much more selectively than we could with
uv
analysis
so then we can do new and change peak
detection that i mentioned before
so once we have those bounding boxes in
the previous slide we can actually
quantify
again on routine samples and test
samples how much of the material has
actually deamidated
and in which fashion but we don't want
to use
we're then having bounding boxes for
example in the reference slide here
we're not actually using the entirety of
this space right there's a lot of white
space where we don't have any signals
so the question then comes up if we're
not monitoring these individual bounding
boxes
what happens if something we're not
expecting pops up at a different mass to
charge
so we have a process related impurity or
product related impurity
in this case we do a direct comparison
using software that essentially
subtracts
the test sample from the reference
sample and we can have it look without
any preconceived notion of the sequence
or the identity of that protein
and say in your reference versus your
test sample has a signal actually
changed
so this is basically asking are there
any new peaks or did any of the peaks
that are in the bounding boxes changed
that we may not be selectively
monitoring in our report so this really
is an agnostic
new or change peak detection it allows
you to identify differences in the
sample
that if they are actually observed you
can then go in with an additional
experiment
to elucidate the identity of those
changes in more detail
so as you can see this is an extremely
complicated method there's a lot of data
processing a lot of data acquisition
that goes into
proper performance of the
multi-attribute method
so what we wanted to do was really
evaluate how well this assay is being
performed across
industry but also identify areas that we
can work together to improve the method
to really allow implementation in both
the product development or process
development side
and hopefully eventually into the
quality control environment
so with this we worked with rich rogers
uh now with bristol meyer squibb to
organize
a combined multi-attribute method
so trina muschauer is a colleague of
mine at nist that's been leading this
study from the nist side and then again
richard
on the bms side has also been helping
along with the mam consortium
which we recruited approximately 30
members throughout industry
to essentially run the same
multi-attribute method
come back together discuss their roles
results
and understand what our current
capabilities are for performing this
analytical method
so the scope of the study again we
really wanted to try to harmonize as
many
aspects of this to really kind of hone
in on the data acquisition component
so in the design we actually did the
digestion at nist to ensure that there
wasn't lab to lab
irreproducibility there so every lab was
actually sent pre-digested samples
shown in the upper left-hand corner we
actually defined the column and gradient
in the blue boxes so each analytical map
each analytical lab
i use the exact same uh plc column and
perform the same gradient
what they were allowed to do was choose
their own equipment so they're able to
use their own uhplc
their own high resolution mass
spectrometer
and you can see on the right hand side
that we actually got a pretty good
sampling of different types of mass
spectrometers
we had q-tops linear ion trap over traps
and
quadrupole-based orbit traps so we tried
to
again limit the variability as much as
we could control and leave it to just
the acquisition and data processing
to understand how this assay was being
performed
and in order to do that we supplied the
users a number of samples
so we supplied them a system suitability
sample
which was basically just a mixture of
individual peptides that are synthetic
that we knew the individual identity of
those peptides
we also supplied them a reference sample
so this is essentially just the digested
mismat
reference material and then we sent them
a couple of these challenge samples to
actually look at their new peak
detection capabilities
so there were three individual samples
one that was a spike sample that had the
15 peptides from the pierce mix
spiked in we also did a stressed
material where the nist map was stressed
with ph to induce high levels of
deamidation
and then we gave them an unknown sample
which was actually just the reference
sample
but on labeled as an unknown to test for
the potential for
false positives so they won't be able to
go through the entirety of this study
today
i can give you a very brief synopsis of
the results and
pointing to the paper that we've
submitted that should be available
in a few months looking at the bottom
right hand corner here we're actually
seeing the results from each of the
individual participants
so each shape on the x-axis represents
an individual pharma lab that
producer analysis and what we can see in
the new peak detection of this spikes
sample is that almost every lab was able
to identify all
15 peptides but some of the labs
identified additional peptides and some
didn't
so some labs found things like modified
spike peptides and spike peptide
impurities
some of these we actually did know are
present from the synthetic
peptide uh synthesis
but they're very very low abundance so
again it really does depend on the
thresholds that you're setting of
whether or not you detect those peptides
in addition there were some nist map
peptides that were detected as either
new or changed
so again this shouldn't have happened in
the individual laboratories but
there was a an issue with column
carryover incomplete washing of some of
the
column components or the autosampler
components etc
that we were able to identify then there
were some unknown m overseas
some of these were due to water
contamination system contamination
uh previous samples etc so while this la
uh
this figure shows that there was some
inconsistencies between the lab there's
a lot of really really good news here
and most everyone was able to identify
all 15 peptides
people were actually setting their new
peak detection criteria within
the current metrics of how
instrumentation was performing
and this was actually based on our
system suitability performance across
the individual labs
and most importantly those that were
deemed false positives or false
negatives could actually be
explained so in the paper we'll actually
go through some of those individual
nuances
where we were able to dig deeper into
the raw data and find some of those
false negatives and false positives and
then some recommendations for
how to go about watching out for these
potential pitfalls that
one could run into so really the future
perspective of mam i think is a very
bright
potential for an analytical assay there
will
definitely be some need for additional
validation criteria a very
good system suitability controls but we
really do believe that this
analytical method has a bright future
and we'll start to see a more broad
implementation of this throughout the
drug development life cycle
so sort of a conclusion on uh nist's uh
kind of current and future state um
obviously we've done a lot of work with
monoclonal antibodies over uh the past
eight or nine years
glycosylation analysis mass spectral
libraries
you name it there's been a lot of
measurements done not to support the
biopharmaceutical specifically
monoclonal antibody field
going from reference materials and now
all the way up into the process
analytics in the upper right hand side
and with that we'd like to continue to
look at other modalities we've actually
started programs in both cartoon
therapies
encapsulated gene therapy mimetic
products
and we're also getting into the rna and
dna-based vaccines
so we really do have a vision as a
national resource
that can provide again the materials in
the science and technology development
to support these emerging modalities and
also the
modalities that have become commonplace
and absolutely necessary
for a solid health care infrastructure
so as a global summary of the nist map
again we really focused on material
properties in releasing this reference
material
there's a very large structural
knowledge base available from nist
as well as 20 plus publications from
stakeholders that have been
put into literature since the material
has been released it's free of
intellectual property so again
anything collected on this material can
in fact be published
it's completely open innovation for
de-risking analytical technology
and it is a perfect common framework for
harmonization
and really understanding across industry
and global
trends and analytical measurements so
just as a reiteration as well we have a
program far beyond maps
we have standards for characterization
that we're developing for a variety of
different
therapeutic modalities and really we're
working on a lot of advanced
analytical characterization standards
etc that can really
be used in the future i think to
characterize these products
and then i'll mention last but not least
that industry challenges really do drive
the science technology and reference
materials will be developed
so there is a robust pandemic response
as well with the current situation
with covet 19 of nist looking at
measurement infrastructure standards and
technology development
that are needed to support uh that field
so with that i'd like to thank a very
large number of folks that have
contributed to this project
over the past year uh the data presented
today is probably 300 plus scientists
throughout industry
that have contributed in some way shape
or form but specifically i'd like to uh
thank the team that is currently working
on some of the mass spectrometry and lc
characterization
uh the biopharma iqs team uh the nist
map team that did a wide variety of
analytical characterization
on the nisnab material and then
specifically call out
our new peak detection round robin
organizers uh risk roger
rich rogers of just now bms uh
and trina mushauer of nist who has been
really leading that effort
so with that i'm very thankful for the
opportunity and i'll look
forward to receiving any questions or
comments that anyone may have
thank you very much